here's it here's a question can we call
Oprah can we call in and tell we're
having a conversation
okay we're with Kevin hope I just asked
you one question
hi and we have uh we've all been in here
telling the stories and talking about
your relationship we've been in tears
and but I just want to understand what
does it mean to see the achievements of
this magnificent young lady to know that
she is one of your daughters but you
have grown you have grown this beautiful
young lady giving your presence your
time your energy your love to somebody
else and then seeing that help somebody
flower into they were supposed to be so
watching Tondo become all that I knew
she could when she first walked into our
little meeting room with a little great
uniform on so many years ago it's it's
been one of life's great rewards to see
that happen and to see her blossom into
this incredible woman that she is still
becoming you know it's not over just get
started but it's a hell of a start you
know all these other girls I think I
have a hundred ninety four girls in
college right now but I lose count
sometimes and she's just representative
of what we've tried to do at the Academy
and what giving a person the opportunity
have an education and see the best of
themselves you do for everybody
Oprah thank you for loaning us your
daughter she's amazing I'll talk to you
soon bye bye I'll call you hey sir
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]